[Music]
everything I do and now all the things I
achieved I still being considered as a
refugee who has freedom yes but limited
being a refugee it doesn't mean that you
cannot be an artist being the refugee
doesn't mean that you are not a human
[Music]
when I dance I feel so free and I feel
complete and that's the only way that I
don't identify myself as a refugee for
me it's very important to dance today in
the European Parliament and such
important day because I want to spread
my message more and more and this is the
best platform to do we are all guests in
this life we are all refugees we are all
living so we should be more nicer to
each other
encinia we grow up living together
Christian Muslim Jewish everybody in the
same neighborhood and then when the war
starts everybody start to take a step
back and I wanted to to choreograph
something to show that we can still be
together if the culture will keep us
together
[Music]
it was a very emotional dance powerful
dance message of peace that was well
conveyed and perceived by a wonderful
dancer from Syria who is dancing instead
of dying together we can we have to have
we have to show empathy solidarity it
was urgent yesterday it was urgent a
year ago and we have to act now
we socialists and Democrats will
continue our fight and refugees we will
welcome them in Europe and share with
them our freedom and solidarity
[Music]
when I was still in the camp my dream it
was to be international dancer and then
during the war I almost forgot about it
but something inside me was telling me
no just keep going keep going I'm here
in Europe I want to learn as much as I
can because one day I believe I will go
back to Syria and it's safe and create a
ballet company there because I think we
needed so much
[Applause]